well that's very interesting you ask me
who my here as well and I said Darwin
Darwin
I think misdiagnosed his own character
traits rather he said that I've become
nothing more than a machine for grinding
theories out of facts
I don't think Darwin was that at all
Darwin was a great hypothesis former
thou infertile ideas he dreamed up ideas
and and which is that the way scientists
ordinarily do work so I think you need
to be imaginative you need to have the
imagination to put together ideas which
other people haven't had you do need to
be able to work hard so Hans Krebs who
discovered the krebs cycle once in my
presence was asked how do you get a
Nobel Prize which he had and he said
it's easy you come into the lab at nine
o'clock in the morning and you leave at
six o'clock in the evening every day for
35 years or words to that effect I don't
think that's how you do it either no
doubt that's part of it but you need a
combination of that and genuine
inspiration which is akin to poetry it's
akin to great art it's a it's a it's the
inventive creative leap which great
scientists have